last year the day after Halloween I came
up with the perfect costume and then I
forgot it then I just forgot what
Halloween was this year and I don't have
anything to wear I'm just not gonna
dress up yeah this is like my first
Halloween doing anything really parents
were strict Christians so I couldn't
really celebrate the devil's day this is
your first time dressing up ever yeah
well that changes a game entirely we're
gonna fight sevens gonna be fun come on
grab as much stuff as you can we'll
figure something out help me with this
rack
I'm boombox McGee I'm a robe guy where's
your leather back chair oh my god you
can pull up a cardigan girl from the
ring or I'm just on TV channels good
pick a meal I'm the worst guy at a party
I'm Indiana Jane or gekkouga I could be
Katniss Katniss I like only one night
yeah no no it's the Paisley policeman
that's pretty scary
one of those cool girls who actually
likes football hi this isn't even for a
costume I just thought it was really
Doug was the last time you've seen it
scroll out on that nice I'm saying that
much right Joe so brown Judge Judy oh my
god you you you've been taking up on air
space oh yeah you think I was born
yesterday yeah you were born yesterday
obviously cuz your crackhead
[Music]
I was the basketball okay I guess
Shaquille O'Neal the scale photo more
yeah I just don't like I can keep the
voice up all night globetrotter oh oh
cool Arthur I'm my uncle Larry I'm a mom
from stranger things I know dude this is
just a stick of cinnamon crystal boy
you'd be like that girl from Harry
Potter who tells the fortune and she
predicts the future the no one believes
her she has the whole prophecy and no
one listened and then she was also a
Love Actually she had a great little
part Love Actually she listened to um
what was her name Joni Mitchell she
listened to Joni Mitchell and then she
dated Alan Rickman Riv also in Harry
Potter okay I think I got it
this is what I landed on yeah saying hey
you're me yeah your uncle Larry yeah
he'll appreciate that he's dead so
[Music]